I checked my Instagram and we were
talking about earlier where a buddy
Vince sent me this clip this dude
dressing up in this colorful poncho in
Boyle Heights
of all [ __ ] places yeah and he has a
mustache in a sombrero and I guess he
was doing like a Mexican skit right yeah
and he's getting called out for it and
let's watch this video guys can we can
we do it like on yeah on live just put
it on I want to see it
okay so just play it okay so this is the
first part now I'm gonna try to like put
it in the mics everyone can hear version
looking guy poncho oh she said that with
such lack of alright else video one okay
this video too so basically they're
standing there and you like what you're
an animal like the guy in the poncho is
like you're an animal you you can't talk
about it and then yeah the one guy's
like well yeah I'm the animal I'm over
here disrespecting a whole culture or
whatever anyways yeah man this is crazy
so I don't know like maybe you could I
don't know if we could put the video on
or whatever but I'm just gonna explain
if you can't see for the people that are
listening apparently this guy is
Egyptian okay
and he was like nah no it's cool it's
cool magician all right
you're still not Mexican gunfire yeah
right yeah and then his girlfriend's
white and then so like you know
obviously Mexicans didn't like it that
he was standing there in a poncho don't
get the [ __ ] out of here not of all
places man Boyle Heights you don't [ __ ]
around in a hood man yeah the body oh
man like I think it's just weird
nowadays cuz like with all the
gentrification and all these people
moving in an LA like they just do not
[ __ ] understand how she will go bad
here yeah no it is real yeah like dudes
get shot dudes get beat up stabbed
whatever like and you know it's just you
don't want to go there didn't disrespect
a group of people that will throw down
like it's not [ __ ] Santa Monica like
this ain't you know you don't [ __ ]
around right a certain place and I feel
like in that area two things already
kind of sensitive because their area is
getting gentrified right so they're
seeing like all the stuff they loved as
a kid disappear and go away yeah and
they see a bunch of flannel Dan
checkered shirts come in with their
[ __ ] you know expensive coffee and
their mustaches yeah and they see their
their childhood going away and then you
had these guys or this Egyptian man he
thought it was cool he goes I'm Egyptian
I basically look Mexican
it doesn't really work like that hey
just because your people made the Sphinx
does not make it okay just cuz you look
Mexican too it's like hey I'm one of you
guys not you not dude like you know I
went down there rollin with the poncho I
think first of all they'd laugh at me
cuz I'd look ridiculous yeah but also
just the whole YouTube [ __ ] right like
people doing it for clout people doing
it to make it ya know like they get it
they think oh you guys doing a [ __ ]
skit here right right this is a good
like basically yar yar mocking yeah
you're mocking us in our city right in
front of us you think we're just gonna
stay here and watch y'all like be like
oh yeah can I be a part of the sketch
like it's just it's it's mean at least
have some Mexicans with you that's what
I'm saying I'm like have your Mexican
homies you know mean which you'd be like
hey na doc you cool doc hey that's my
gypsy homie
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] it yeah yeah at least
or if you're gonna do that [ __ ] do that
[ __ ] at your crib yeah your message
you're saying you got a good message for
whatever what's the message yeah well I
don't know what messaging positivity
dude yeah like roads do it at your crib
man to where you're not you're in your
own you know personal space you can
still wear your poncho like just let
people make those decisions on comments
you know you're safe it's still a piece
of [ __ ] thing see my thing is like a
wearing like like that's like me wearing
a what is it
kimono or yeah yeah yeah and then if I
was making a skit skit about it so am I
like there's the line of like what's
gonna be funny and then what's going to
be racist you know like why why don't I
cast somebody who's Asian well because
this is my page and I'm the comedian and
I want to play this role to portray this
yeah you know I mean or behind I
actually have no problems with that like
if you if you made a skit right and like
like we have this one skit where we're
like slanging tee right and we have one
of our black buddies that comes in and
he's like buying tea from us and we're
like acting all hood but we're wearing
like traditional Chinese clothes or like
you know I have cholo characters that I
played a lot of different characters
Manna Dey
yeah so like my cholo characters our
Asians that grew up in like Mexico and
stuff and then so so they have that like
like wow like that kind of East LA kind
of style yeah and you're right though if
you do it like in a setting that's like
you're not doing it outdoors like
[ __ ] with people all right I don't
know what this is about but it it looks
like they're outdoors [ __ ] with the
community yeah like pranks and [ __ ] yeah
yeah I don't know how to prank to go to
a blood city a blood street wearing
wearing all blue bandana let's all you
know everything blue a whole blue unit
and thinking like I bro
so we're on a blood street right now
let's check it out you know saying and
they're just like [ __ ] walking down the
hallway
make this top side of this so sorry you
owe me 100 bucks bro know what you just
gave me a great video idea doing that
tomorrow I gotta make it from one stop
side to the other
yeah that will be hilarious and then
they get shot up and [ __ ] yeah
dude every time I saw see like these
pranks like I said I always pray just
please one of them died I just want one
of them to die
I just wanted to happen once I just want
somebody to get shot just be like I
[ __ ] told you so yeah because some
people would be scared of it but nobody
has really faced those consequences you
think you're like a like a neutral
reaction to like book he was he was like
a martyr like he's doing something great
for the society like yeah [ __ ] like
hero like this is for positivity man and
blaming the the guys like so you can't
blame the guy for being offended that
you're [ __ ] with his culture like
you're like why I gotta be an animal and
try to fight me for it's like man what
the [ __ ] are you saying
right right like if I went to the South
and I walked around called all these
black people n-word and they get mad at
me and it's like what went down
yeah dude like I deserve to get my ass
beat at that point there's always a line
right some people believe like you
should never be violent no matter what I
don't [ __ ] believe that [ __ ] if you
provoke someone enough and you're just
being a complete [ __ ] yeah maybe you
should get your ass beat in that way
yeah some people do need a couple
absolutely yeah I'm saying just just to
straighten up to be like oh maybe that
was [ __ ] up if you go up to a [ __ ]
lion right and you poke that
[ __ ] with a stick all day you
deserve to get bit yeah first your facts
I like this girlfriend because she was
she was not down she was a fishy way I'm
not leaving without any more than that
you dumb [ __ ] let's let's talk about
their channels so you you said it was
what Dan and stupid in pictures it was
like okay Kimo Kimo and Danny David did
a good job finding their [ __ ]
histogram pay I mean their YouTube page
and then they just do like
pranks or whatever it's like cloud chase
market like yeah tried being homeless in
Dubai Indonesia and villagers try
rapping Drake songs whatever yeah here's
the hard part
um I think Tim actually explained this
really well he was he was talking about
the whole situation where a bunch of
youtubers they do a lot of crazy [ __ ]
right yeah and and they gain a lot of
attention for it after a while they just
stop being human because they don't know
what's real and what's not
yeah yeah cuz [ __ ] with them cuz
they're trying to create any type of
story any type of fervor on a daily
basis right so they don't know what
those boundaries are anymore even
sometimes - like when we're out like so
Tim does is one thing now where he just
goes before he flawless eagles hate vlog
warning and he says that just to let
people know if they don't want to
participate in this they don't have to
mmm but prior to that he probably didn't
do it and but now he knows like oh not
everybody wants to be in this type of
world right so it's a very odd thing
where sometimes when you have to create
content every day these kids they just
don't understand what it's like live
well you gotta let people know like I'm
going live because so you we can just be
talking we could be talking [ __ ] about
somebody or you talking [ __ ] above
something that you wouldn't want people
that you're comfortable around your
friends and you got one person on live
and now they hear Joe in the background
no talking this [ __ ] and you're like
[ __ ] bro like yep you know that's
happened to us weed inner circle the
friends man yeah man like a lot of thick
is it serious bro you know that should
happen just gotta call it out to like
hey I'm vlogging so then people know oh
[ __ ]
right right would like [ __ ] when
codec was talking a [ __ ] about [ __ ]
oh man yeah you shouldn't you shouldn't
have like that conversation I can see
that the conversation happening behind
closed doors behind closed doors your
home was you're talking dumb [ __ ] cuz
obviously it's dump [ __ ] let's get that
out the way that you're saying some
ignorant [ __ ] yeah but the fact that you
got the camera on and it's his live I
would assume you say it like bro no bro
the funny thing was when he was when he
wanted to squash the whole thing and I
think he went on his Instagram live and
he was like yo well this is what it is
he's like you know how was giving her a
comp cleaning it up yeah
so this is what his girlfriend said
right so she sent a DM to this dude and
then she's like so she says by the way
my family and I are immigrants and we
only came to the States from Eastern
Europe like ten years ago and are not
rich and privileged as all racist people
think so crazy only the USA has such big
degree of racism the rest of the world
doesn't like this all I want is to end
that in this country as well maybe the
approach suck then we will learn from
this but at least chemo and I are
willing to put ourselves out there and
try
most people just talking complain about
it but never act on it one day when you
feel when you travel and see the world
and experience different people and
cultures you will realize cultural
appropriation is only a problem in the
USA and if we keep approaching it and
racism with hate bla bla bla
you know what's crazy is this [ __ ] has
no [ __ ] idea what the American
experience is all about obviously
cultural appropriation is a sensitive
topic in the u.s. because we had racism
and we had one group that was very
powerful yeah and they would you know
like for example like you know
incarcerate people for no [ __ ] reason
they wanted to or whatever yeah and she
just doesn't understand race
relationships in the in the u.s. of
course it's gonna be since this country
is literally made off of appropriation
well we've got wait what was the word we
use duplication cultural appropriation
project yeah proprietary yeah yeah yeah
so she's like why why and she's right
too cuz like in Japan they love it when
foreigners come and wear kimonos and and
dress up in the costumes and play all
that [ __ ] because it's tourism and they
don't have the pass hurt right but but
out here in the u.s. if if people are
pretending to be Asian and they [ __ ]
around and do their eyes [ __ ] and then
they wear like ching chong clothes or
whatever the [ __ ] and if they act around
that does it feels different mm-hmm but
if they're out in asia doing it it's not
that we
and so she's kind of she's I mean her
response is [ __ ] stupid - because she
goes well that's not how it is at the
rest of the world so if you're so
well-traveled right then you should
understand that every time you go to a
country everybody has a different set of
rules and if you're respectful in that
country of their set of rules why can't
you do the same over here then so what
is the change that you're trying to
invoke here right so for example if she
if she travelled - if she went into my
house right and then she didn't want to
take off her shoes because she goes in
my house I didn't I don't give a [ __ ]
pick up your [ __ ] shoes off in my
house I'll slice your feet off about
that [ __ ] but so it doesn't her logic
doesn't make sense if she goes it's kind
of what do you call it egotistical -
yeah she's like once you [ __ ] travel
you'll understand you're talking like
sometimes people can't afford it yeah
yeah like what [ __ ] yeah and you're
saying we're not as privileged it's like
obviously you don't understand it some
people just can't afford to travel or
see the world understand outside of
their city like that makes you that is
what privilege is yeah you don't you're
blind to seeing that some people just
can't do that right and if you're trying
to like spread a positive message okay
and you're this is uh let's say you're
trying to do a message for um you know
Korea
you're not gonna for your for your video
you're not gonna dress in a Korean
outfit and then say your message yeah
you can actually still be yourself or be
any other character that's true and
spread your positive message you don't
have to be in a poncho of fake-ass like
curly ass mustache occurs at the ends
and a poncho like in our sombrero then
just spread your message for what what
was that for
yeah is a good question what the [ __ ]
was the message is this positivity yeah
Holly watch this [ __ ] yeah it
happened so many with so much so many
[ __ ] youtubers do this [ __ ] doing
it about time people get checked for
their [ __ ] yeah it's kind of weird
and how the entitlement like how people
think that it's like man I'm doing this
[ __ ] message for good see the
internet social media and everything it
allows people to be their own celebrity
yeah so now now
yeah my fans need me I'm doing this for
the world I'm trying to spread this and
I'm trying to change this and you
actually need to learn your position
yeah and play that role and then you
know once you continue being that role
you progress and then you'll end up
being the person that you want to be but
right now